[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي عيال اختيار السهلوها بابره
العالم
يدرس امكانيه ارسال القبه الحديديه الى
اوكرانيا
اهداف مشروعه
عبر العربيه الديمقراطيه لكردستانيه
الايرانيه تعاهدوا بالدفاع عن نفسه اذا
هاجم الطهران اقليم كردستان
وخلال تفتيش المفاجئ وكاله الطاقه الدوليه
تعلن اكتشاف اجهزه طرد مركزي غير معلن
عنها بايران
[تصفيق]
على تدني الاجور وارتفاع الاسعار بريطانيا
تشهد اكبر اضراب في عهد الملك تشارلز
[موسيقى]
نبدا مشاهدينا من تهديد موسكو لتل ابيب اذ
حذرت الخارجيه الروسيه اسرائيل من ارسال
الاسلحه الى كياف ماريا زخرفه قالت ان
بلادها لا تصنف الدول بحسب الجغرافيا وان
كل الدول التي تسلم اسلحه يجب ان تفهم ان
اسلحتها ستعتبر اهداف المشروعه للقوات
الروسيه تحديدات زخرفه وصلت باريس ايضا
حذرت من تزويد فرنسا بالمقاتلات ووصفت
تصريحات ماكرون حول الموضوع بالسخيف مشدده
على ان التصعيد الروسي هو الرد
حول
اوكرانيا بالسلاح نحن لا نقسم الدول وفق
مبدا الجغرافيا ما نقول ان جميع الدول
التي تزود اوكرانيا بالاسلحه يجب ان تفهم
اننا سنعتبر هذه الاسلحه اهدافا مشروعه
للقوات المسلحه الروسيه
الى اوكرانيا
لمزيد من المشاركه الناشطه ففي مقابله مع
شبكه
عن ما اذا كان بامكان اسرائيل تقديم
المساعده لاوكرانيا في مجالات مثل القلب
الحديديه التي تحمي اسرائيل من الهجمات
الجويه كماكد انه يدرس هذا الامر بالفعل
واكد انه انا الولايات المتحده نقلت
مخزونا من ذخيره المدعيه المخصصه لاسرائيل
الى اوكرانيا مقارنه بين هذا الجهد
والعمليات التي تشنها بلاده ضد الطائره
[موسيقى]
وفي اطار التحديدات الروسيه قال رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه الروسيه النحل فنيته
يزيد رهان في اوكرانيا لانه مازال يحلم
بهزيمه روسيا استراتيجيا وانا احلام هذه
لن تتحقق في ما اكد رئيس اللجنه العسكريه
في وقت سابق استعداد الحلف للمواجهه
المباشره مع روسيا من جانبه قال المتحدث
باسم الكريم
دعايه حتى الان لا توجد خطط لاجراء
محادثات بين بوتين هدفنا الرئيسي الان هو
مواصله العمليه العسكريه الخاصه ونهدف
ايضا الى تنفيذ المهام المحدده هناك
مستجدات في الوقت الحاضر نرى ان البنيه
التحتيه العسكريه للناتو تعملو ضد الاتحاد
الروسي كما ان البنيه التحتيه الاستطلاعيه
للناتو باكملها في ذلك الطائرات والاقمار
الصناعيه تعمل على مدار الساعه طوال ايام
الاسبوع لصالح اوكرانيا بالطبع كل هذا
يخلق ظروفا عاديا لا يسعنا الا ان ناخذها
في الاعتبار
في المقابل قالت رئيسه مجلس الاتحاد
الاوروبي انا روسيا مستعده للمفاوضات بشان
اوكرانيا في حال جاهزيه لهذه الخطوه
واشارت الى ان اوكرانيا غير مستعده لاجراء
مفاوضات حقيقيه حتى الان في وقتنا لم
تبدوا واشنطن استعدادا ايضا للمفاوضات في
ظل استمرار دعمها باسلحه هجوميه
زار وزير الدفاع الالمانيه
وتهدف الزياره للاشراف على القدرات
التشغيليه للدبابات
[موسيقى]
معنى من مصطفى عبله
العسكري استاذ بابل
اعتمدت منذ بدا الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
سياسه السير بين النقاط وطبعا عدم اثاره
غضب بوتن بسبب المصالح الامنيه
واستراتيجيه بين الطرفين خصوصا في سوريا
هل ممكن اليوم ان تذهب الى اقدار بوتين
واعطاء اوكرانيا اسلحه
موت برزنت بتاع الكويت
لاسلحه مميته الى اوكرانيا
في اسرائيل
وفرت الكثير من صواريخ سبايك المضاده
للدبابات الى
اوروبا واقامه ببناء مصنع في المانيا
لتوفير هذه الاسلحه
اوروبا لكن هذه الدول غير مسموح لها
باعاده تصدير هذه الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا
وفي الوقت الراهن اعتقد سوف يواصل له تبني
موقف المدافع وقال هو انه ربما قد يقوم
بالوساطه بين
موسكو وهذا يعني انه ليس مستعد لتبني اي
موقف واضح فلا دا اسرائيل المشكله
يرغب في الوقت الراهن اغضاب روسيا
قالت لي التلميح بان خسرتها للحرب تعني
نمومه يعرف بمعادات الساميه في دول
الاتحاد
السمن وحتى داخل روسيا هذه النقطه بالذات
يعني كيف ممكن ان ترد عليها كيف
روسيا او ما في حاله تصادم
فروسيا في الواقع همم ترغب اوروبا ما في
حدوث
كان يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق النار
همم
الحاليه خطوط الجبهه الحاليه لتجميد
الوضع وهذا ما قام به
شرق الاوسط عام
1973 من خلال تجميد الاوضاع في هضبه
الجولان وهذا ما تريده روسيا لكنه اوكراني
ليست مساعد حاليا هذا يعني انه بالتاكيد
سيكون هناك المزيد من القتال
الجيش الاوكراني يعتقد انه يستطيع ان يحقق
الكثير على المعركه وهو كاي ان الشعب ولا
الجيش ولا القدر السياسيين على استعداد
للحلول الوسط وهذا يعني ان او في الوقت
الراهن سوف يستمر القتال قبل ان يكون هناك
ربما مواقف لدى الطرفين تسمحوا
بحصول تقارب بينهم
مبالغ فيه عندما تستخدمه ويعتبره نوع من
الدعايه بالنسبه لاسلحه الاسلحه الطويله
المدى او الصواريخ طويلات المدى من
المعلوم بان الجانب الغربي سيمد اليوم
اوكرانيا لصواريخ بعيده الماده تصل الى
150 كيلو متر ولكن عاد الحديث عن عن ضروره
امداد اوكرانيا باسلحه تصل مداها الى 300
كيلو متر للضرب المستودعات مستودعات
الاسلحه الروسيه في المناطق التي تعتبرها
اوكرانيا يعني محتله او مستولى عليها كيف
يمكن ان ترد همم موسكو على هذه الخطوه
وكيف يمكن ان تؤثر اصلا امدادات هذه على
نشره الحرب
اعوضي
الاسلحه او هذه الصواريخ التي تطلق من
البر ولا يبدو ان الولايات المتحده سوف
تسلمها الى اوكرانيا
فهي بالاساس عباره عن قنابل
استخدمتها او استخدمها الجيش الاسرائيلي
كثيره في سوريا ضد اهداف ايرانيه بالاساس
بالتاكيد هذه الاسلحه فتاكه ويمكن ان تلقى
من الطائرات كما تفعل اسرائيل من علمتني
الطائرات 16 اما هو كذلك عبر القاذفات
الصواريخ مثل هاي مارس او اي انظمه همم
انظمه اسلحه اخرى طبعا هذا سيكون همم عامل
سي يغير قواعد اللعبه لان المدام مهم جدا
اا وخاصه عندما يكون هناك صواريخ من هذا
القبيل وتتوفر على المعلومات الدقيقه فهذه
الاسلحه همم يمكن ان تنطلق بسرعه كبيره
وهي
توجهه ضد الاهداف مباشره وبعض المراقبين
في موسكو يقولون ان روسيا سيكون بوسعها
الصعيد خطير ويمكن ان يكون الامر وكذلك
ليس واضحا حاليا ما ستقوم به مسك للرد على
ذلك قد تسعى ربما
لانتظار وصول هذه الاسلحه ولكن سيغير ذلك
قواعد اللعبه على ساحه المعركه حيث يمكن
استهداف مراكز القياده والتحكم الروسيه
الصواريخ يمكن ايضا ان تصل الى اعماق
كبيره وتصل الى
المترين من الدفاعات الخرسانيه ثم تنفجر
هذه اسلحه خطيره للغايه واذا ما استخدمها
الاوكرانيون بكامل قوتها فهي ستغير الكثير
على ساحه المعركه
وعن المساعدات العسكريه في من المتوقع ان
تشمل الحزمه الامريكيه الجديده صواريخ
بعيده المدى لاول مره وذخائر واسلحه اخرى
ابرز هذه الاسلحه صواريخ جاء الاس دي بي
القنبليه او القنبله الانزلاقيه فما ابرز
مميزات هذه الاسلحه
صواريخ جي ال اس دي بي او القنبله
الانزلاقيه يبلغ مداها 150 كيلومترا يسمح
المدى الاطول لصاروخ جي ال اس دي بي
لاوكرانيا بضرب اهداف عسكريه بعيده
ومساعدتها على مواصله هجماتها المضاده
وتعطيل روسيا بشكل اكبر جي ال اس دي بي
يتم تصنيعها بالاشتراك بين بوينج وسابق
تجمع بين قنبله جي بي يو 39 ذات القطر
الصغير ومحرك الصاروخ ام 26 يتم توجيه
صواريخ الاس دي بي بواسطه نظام gps
ويمكنها التغلب على بعض التشويش
الالكترونيه
واستخدامها في جميع الظروف الجويه وضد
المركبات المدرعه
الانزلاقيه
مسيرتان بدولار واحد فقط عرض امريكي
لاوكرانيا لمساعده الاخيره بالدفاع عن
نفسها في الوقت الذي تستعد فيه لهجوم
روسيا متوقع قبيله الربيعه المقبل فوفقا
ان لمواسطه الامريكيه شركات جنرال اتومكس
الامريكيه التي تعتبر من اكبر الشركات
للصناعات العسكريه في العالم عرضت على
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه بيع كل طائرتين
من دون طيار من طراز ام كيو 9 ريبر مقابل
الدولار واحد الصفقه ستتطلب منك انفاق
حوالي 10 ملايين دولار لاعاده وشحن
الطائرات الى اوكرانيا وحوالي ثمانيه
ملايين دولار الى لكل عام لصيانه هذه
الطائرات من دون طبعا طيار القديمه والتي
لا يتم استخدامها حاليا في اوكرانيا العرض
يشمل ايضا محطه تحكم ارضيه لتشغيل
الطائرات من دون طيار في اي مكان على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وفقا لرساله
الصحيفه الامريكيه انها طلعت عليها مسيرات
هي ليست مسلحه ولكن يمكن حملها في حقيبه
على الظهر وتستخدم لتصطدم بالاهداف يبلغ
طول جناحي
حوالي 66 قدما ويمكن تسليحها كما يمكنها
ايضا ان تطير لاكثر من اربعه وعشرين ساعه
البيت الابيض الذي سيتعين عليه الموافقه
على صفقه البيع رفض التعليق على الامر حتى
الان واشنطن كانت قد قدمت في العام الماضي
اكثر من 700 طائره من دون طيار اصغر الى
اوكرانيا بما في ذلك طائرات من دون طيار
تكتيكيه من طراز سويتش بليت
[موسيقى]
على الارض بعد معارك عنيفه تمكنت القوات
الروسيه عمليا من تطويق مدينه باخمود التي
يجرى فيها القتال الان من اجل السيطره
عليها من ثلاثه محاور وتعمل على طرد
القوات الاوكرانيه من مواقعها هذا واكدت
سلطات المحليه في جمهوريات لوجاست الشعبيه
ان القوه الروسيه تحاول ان تقدم الى مدينه
ساسوفيار الخاضعه لسيطره اكياس والتي يتم
عبرها
بشكل مكثف القوات الروسيه تعمل ايضا بشكل
منها شيء على قطع الخطوط الامداد والاتصال
على القوات الاوكرانيه في باخمود وحصرها
بين فكي كماشه في حين تدور المعارك في
ضحايا وضاحي المدينه وتحديدا في تلك
الاحياء التي سيطرت عليها الوحدات
الاوكرانيه مؤخرا موافقه طبعا السلطات
المحليه
مازالت الاعمال العسكريه مستمره في جنوب
وشرق اوكرانيا وما زالت مقاطعه
دانيستشهدوا اعنف المعارك على الاطلاق
تزامنا مع وصوله امدادات عسكريه من روسيا
لا سيما بعد اعلان موسكو عن التعبئه
الجزئيه اواخر العامل الماضي فشمال
المقاطعه يشهدوا تقدما للقوات الروسيه على
الاراضي التي سيطر عليها الجيش الاوكراني
سابقا وقواته فاجنر بسطت نفودها على مزيد
من الاراضي والبلدات حول مدينه بعد ان
اكملت السيطره على جوانبها الثلاثه وتقطع
الامدادات عن المقاتلين الاوكرانيين
المحاصرين داخل المدينه من الطرق السريعه
المؤديه من الناحيه الغربيه الى مدينتي
شسوفيا
وتحاول قوته اختراق مدينه باخمط من
الناحيه الجنوبيه حيث تنطلق العمليات
العسكريه من مدينه كليشكا وصولا الى مدينه
ايفانكا وتتقدم القوات الروسيه من شمال
باخمود نحو مدينه سيفرز التي يسيطر عليها
الجيش الاوكراني بعد سيطرهم على مدينتين
لقداتنا وسوليدار ومزيد من البلدان لقناتي
العربيه والحدث رائد الاخضر
حضر الرئيس من ان بلاده لن تسمح بقصف
المناطق الروسيه من قبل اوكرانيا مؤكدان
ان هذه اولويه الان وهي من اختصاص وزارات
الدفاع الروسيه تاكيد فوتر هذا ياتي بعد
تعرض خط انابيب دروجبا للقصف الصاروخي
المتجه من اوكرانيا ما قد يعطل خطه تصدير
خلال الاسابيع المقبله
[موسيقى]
لابد من وجود طرف داخلي لاتهامه بالعماله
والتخمر نهج لطالما اتبعته طهران مع كل
ضربه اسرائيليه او امريكيه داخل ايران او
عندما تواجه الاحتجاجات ففي حادثه الضربه
الاخيره على مصنع اسلحه في اصفهان وجهها
النظام الايراني اتهاماته لاحزاب كرديه
معارضه تتخذ من كردستان العراق مقل لها
مقر لها بانها هي من ادخلت المسيارات الى
داخل الاراضي الايرانيه اتهامات رفضها
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني في ايران عبر
مقابله خاصه مع العربيه اذ قال زعيم الحزب
الكردي والمطلوب الاول للنظام الايراني ان
سياسه تصدير الازمه هي طريقه تنتجها طهران
في كل هجوم او مازقت وجهها
كوماري سميرا
جمهوريه ايران الاسلاميه ردا على اي
احتجاج من قبل الشعب الايراني حتى
الاحتجاجات التي اعقبت القتل الوحشي
لامراه بسبب عدم ارتدائها حجاب الراس بشكل
مناسب يتهم النظام الجميع بانهم عملاء
للاجانب وانهم اعداء الاسلام يتهم النظام
حزبنا بارسال اسلحه الى داخلي ايران في
الواقع يقف الشعب ضد قوات امن النظام
بايديهم العاريه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ايضا في مقابله مع العربيه اكد زعيم الحزب
الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني ان حزبه
سيدافع عن نفسه اذا شنت ايران هجوما بريا
على كردستان العراق واضاف ان طهران تضغط
بشكل مستمر على حكومه اقليم كردستان لنزع
السلاح حزبه المعارض وحل قوه البشمركه
من قبل الجمهوريه الاسلاميه على كردستان
العراق سندافع عن انفسنا سنقاوم قصف
النظام بكل قوتنا كما فعلنا حتى اليوم
لطالما ضغطت الجمهوريه الاسلاميه على
حكومه اقليم كردستان في العراق انهم
يضغطون على حكومه الاقليم لنزع سلاح حزبنا
وحل قوه البيشمركه لكننا قومنا ذلك بالرغم
من كل الضغوط نحن نخطط للاستمرار في
القيام بذلك سوف نحمي انفسنا لان بغداد
واربيل تتعرضان دائما لضغوط النظام
الايراني
العربيه تمكنت ايضا من الوصول الى مخابئ
ومقار واحد من اهم الاحزاب المعارضه الحزب
الديمقراطيه الكردستانيه الايراني و رصدت
ما يجري بداخل معسكره السري الذي يقع على
بعد كيلو متر واحد من الحدود الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
خمسه احزاب ايرانيه معارضه كرديات تنشط في
المهجر اهمها وابرزها الحزب الديمقراطيه
الكردستانيه الايرانيه المعارض حزب قومي
يقول انه ليس متشددا ولا انفصاليا نحن
اليوم في جبل حاره
وسيله اعلاميه تصل الى معسكر تابع للحزب
في هذا الجبل على بعد كيلو متر واحد من
الحدود الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
لكنها لا تحجب رؤيه ورقبه النظام
نحن قاربون من الحدود الايرانيه وهي منطقه
تتعرض باستمرار لتحديد الطائرات المسيره
والصواريخ الايرانيه
تتهم طهران الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني المعارض بدعم المظاهرات الاخيره
اثاره الشغب انطلاقا من اراضي العراق تهمه
النفاهه الحزب لكن الحرس الثوري استمر في
شان ضربات متتاليه على مواقعه ومخابئه في
كردستان العراق
[تصفيق]
هذه صور حصريه لقناه العربيه تظهر القصف
الذي شنه النظام الايراني على مواقع الحزب
في نمر الماضي
حاول النظام تقويض الانتفاضه المدنيه عبر
جرنا الى صراع العسكري
الايراني
عام
1940 قبل ان تسقط يعود الحزب من المشاركه
في الثوره الايرانيه ضد الشهره لم تنتهي
القصه هنا
شهيده اثر المرشد الايراني الخميني عام
1979 فتوى ضد من سماهم بالمتمردين الاكراد
وكان يقصد حينها الاحزاب الكرديه
الايرانيه المعارضه التي طالبت
بالديمقراطيه والحكم الذاتي منذ ذلك الحين
بدات هذه الاحزاب صراعا مع السلطه صراع
دفع بعضهم الى مغادره البلاد واقامه
معسكرات في كردستان العراق
للاحزاب الكرديه الايرانيه هنا مكاتب
ومقرات تنشط فيها سياسيا كما لها مخابئ
ومواقع للتدريب على السراحه ان كانت تشدد
على ان المواجهه المسلحه مع النظام مؤجله
الان
طبعا امل ولا اجبر على استخدام السلاح
ولكن اذا اضطرنا الى ذلك فسنستخدم الاسلحه
ليس فقط ضد الحارس الثوري الايراني ولكن
ضد اي شخص يريد سلب حريتنا
[موسيقى]
الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه
محمد صالح
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني
استاذ محمد يعني اتهامات متتاليه للاحزاب
الكرديه لتشتيت الراي العام الداخلي
والخارجي هذه الاتهامات وكل ما تفعله يعني
طهران اليوم لشهر الاكراد الى حرب مفتوحه
مع ايران هل ممكن ان تنجح فيها
الجمعه
يواجهها النظام الايراني لنا
هي اداه تستخدمها بشكل دائم بحقنا ولا
توجد لها اي اساس من الصحه وهي فقط
تريد التوجيه الاتهامات الى الاكراد في
ايران حتى انها تهدد في اقليم كردستان
العراق لاننا نتواجد هناك
وفي اخر اربعه اشهر مضد
في مناطق الكرديه في ايران
قامت ثوره انتفاضه ضد النظام
واجهها طبعا تلك المظاهرات السلميه بالقتل
والسلاح
وبالمقابل همم حاول النظام ان يطفئ هذه
المظاهره هذه التظاهرات والاحتجاجات ضد
وبدات بالضغط ايضا على الاحزاب الكرديه
بالمعارضه والتوجيه الاتهامات
حتى انها اتهمت اقليم كردستان العراق
بانها
تساند المحزب المعارضه
وتريد
عبر ذلك تمهد لضرب اربيل واقليم كردستان
العراق بحجه ان هذه الاحزاب
تتواجد هناك لكن حكومه الاقليم ايضا هي
خرجت ونحن نؤكد اننا همم ليست لدينا اي
اي ارتباط بالهجوم على اصفهان
وبحسب كل ما تم تداوله هو اسرائيل هي من
تقوم وراء من تقف خلف هذا الهجوم وهي تقوم
باتهام
الاحزاب الكرديه والاقليم كردستان العراق
الفصائل الكرديه بخدمه المصالح الغربيه
وتحديدا الاسرائيليه اليوم مع الساعات
الاولى للهجوم اتهمت طبعا اسرائيل بهذا
الهجوم وهي تعتبر الاكراد هم الاداه في
هذا الهجوم كيف تردون على هذا الاتهام
نحن
ننفي هذه الاتهامات بشكل جديد لا يوجد
لديها لهذه الاتهامات اي اساس
هذه بعيده عن الحقيقه
وهي تريد ان تفند الشرعيه
وشرعيه الاحزاب الكرديه والحق حقوق الشعب
الكردي في ايران عبر هذا اتهامات
لا من قريب ولا من بعيد لا يوجد اي
اتصالات بيننا وبين اسرائيل هذه الاتهامات
ليست صحيحه
باستخدام اسم اسرائيل
لاتهامي كل من يعارضها سواء احزاب الكرديه
او غيرها
وهي تريد ان
ان تسقط حقوق الشعب الكردي في ايران عبر
هذه الاتهامات
ونحن ناكد اننا لم نستخدم اراضي اقليم
كردستان لاي تهديد ضد
الاراضي الايرانيه ونؤكد اننا لم نستخدم
لم نهدد من موقعنا همم
الاراضي داخل ايران وهي تريد ان تنتهي ما
اقليم كردستان العراق وحكومه بغداد
وشاكر
وعبر التصريحات
وهذه الاتهامات ليست صحيحه نؤكد مره اخرى
هذه ليست صحيحا
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني
حدثنا من اربيل شكرا لك
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
ازمه الوفاق لم تنتهي العدل الامريكيه
تفتش مجددا منزل بايدن ومحاموه يؤكدونا
عدم العثور على اي شيء
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل ان اكمل ورده قبل الان عاجل
عن القياده المركزيه الامريكيه تؤكد
اعتراض اسلحه ايرانيه كانت متجهه الى
اليمن في شهر يناير الفائت تمكنت البحريه
الفرنسيه من ضبط زورق محمد بالاسلحه
والذخيره الايرانيه في خليجي عمان كان في
طريقه الى جماعه الحوثي في اليمن في اطار
جهود دوليه لمنع تهريب الاسلحه للجامعه
شحنته الاسلحه المهربه تكاد لا تتوقف في
اتجاه جماعه الحوثي في اليمن مره اخرى في
خليج عمان البحريه الفرنسيه تضبط زورقا
يضم اكثر من 3000 بندقيه فضلا عن نصف
مليون رصاصه و20 صاروخا مضادا للدبابات
العمليه جاءت في وقت اصبحت باريس
دورا اكبر في عمليه التصدي لتهرب الاسلحه
في المنطقه بعد ان تصدرت واشنطن المهمه
اكد ان الجيش الامريكي ساعد في مصادره
الشحنه
وخلال شهرين تمكنت واشنطن وشركائها من منع
وصول اكثر من خمسه الاف قطعه سلاح ومليون
وستمائه الف طلقه ذخيره الى اليمن البحريه
الامريكيه كانت قد صادرت اكثر من 2000
بندقيه منقارب في خليج عمان كانت متجهه
الى جماعه الحوثي اضافه الى مخدرات تبلغ
قيمتها 33 مليون دولار من سفينه صيد في
المياه الدوليه في خليج عمان الشحنات
المهربه من الاسلحه الى اليمن ليست والده
اليوم في ديسمبر الماضي اعلنت البحريه
الامريكيه مصادره 1400 بندقيه من طراز اي
كي سبعه واربعين من على متن سفينه صيد
شماليه بحر العرب كانت قادمه من ايران كما
صدرت اكثر من مليون ومئه الف طلقه من
سفينه صيد تعمل بين ايران واليمن
ثم منذ انقلاب ميليشيه الحوثي في اليمن
اواخر عام 2014 كشفت ايران عمليات تهريب
الاسلحه جوا و برا وبحرا وعبر كل
المنافذين العربيه
لتخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه تصل الى 60% في
محطه فردوس واكدت الوكاله الذريه ان ايران
ابلغتها بتحولها لاستخدام اجهزه طرد مركزي
جديده بعد ما تم اكتشافها مشيره الى ان
ايران غيرت في تصميمات تستخدم في انتاج
اليورانيوم دون ابلاغ الوكاله واعتبرت
وكاله الطاقه الذريه ان الاجراءات
الايرانيه تقود القدره على تنفيذ تدابير
الضمانات النوويه
هذا هو اعتبرته الوزيره الفرنسيه للشؤون
الاوروبيه ان النظام الايراني يغرق في
حاله من الانكار ونظريه المؤامره وقالت
الوزيره الفرنسيه ان العقوبات التي قال
النظام الايراني انه فرضها على الاوروبيين
تدل على انهم نظام يعاني من قصر النظر
واضافت ان العقوبات التي فرضتها ايران لا
يمكن ان تقارن بالعقبات التي فرضها
الاتحاد الاوروبي
في ايران ايضا وملف الاحتجاجات الدم يسيل
في دم الوطن هكذا هتفت الانتفاضه الشعبيه
في ايران لتصر على استمراريتها رغم كل
محاولات القمع والترهيب والتخويف من قبل
النظام الايراني هتافات النساء في لم تهدا
في حي بناك في العاصمه طهران وصدى اصواتهن
اكد على الموت للديكتاتور الموت ليخه من
السماء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
المظاهرات والاضرابات والتجمعات والهتفات
وحرق رموز النظام وغيرها من اشكال العصيان
المدني عمت مختلف المدن الرئيسيه في
البلاد وكما نشاهد على هذه الشاشه
مشاهدينا ادرار النار بتمثال لقاسم
سليماني قائد فيلق القدس السابق في مدينه
كوبن جنوب البلاد صحيفه وصله
الامريكي استبدلوا احتجاجات الشوارع
المميته بحسب قولها باعمال تمرد هادئه
واهمها تخلي الاف النساء في ايران عن
الحجاب الالزاميه هذه الخطوه اعتبرتها
الصحيفه الامريكيه شكلا من اشكال العصيان
المدنيه وقد لا تطيح بالنظام لكن سيكون من
الصعب احتوائها في المستقبل طبعا ولكنها
اشارت الى ان القيود التي فرضتها السلطات
لم يكن لها تاثير كبير موضحه ان التحول
العلمانيه في ايران اخذ في التوسع وفقه
وصفها والقمع هذا المسار الجديد فرض
النظام الايراني هذا الشهر غرامات على
النساء
يخالفن قواعد اللباس في الاماكن العامه
[موسيقى]
اندلع حريق ضخم في مستشفى النور المحمديه
الخيري بمنطقه في القاهره تسبب بفو- بوفاه
ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه 32 اخرين على الاقل
بحاله اختناق وهكذات قوه الحمايه المدنيه
انتقال سيارات الاطفال لموقع الحريق الذي
لم يتم التعرف على اسباب حتى الان في
مؤكدت ان عمليات الاطفال مستمره لمحاوله
السيطره على الحريق
[موسيقى]
تحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي عن اطلاق سفارات
الانذار في مدينه سديرات ومنطقه غلاف قطاع
غزه فيما افاد مراسل العربيه ان بطاريه
قبل الحديديه الاسرائيليه اعترضت صاروخا
اطلق من قطاع غزه واشار هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه الى اصابه شخص بجروح بعد
اعتراض الصاروخ
الى سوريا حيث افاده المسلسل السوري لحقوق
الانسان بمقتل 14 عناصر بينهم ضابط في قصر
صاروخيه على موقع تابع لقوات النظام في
ريف ادلب الجنوبي وقال المرصد الهيئه
تحرير الشام استهدف احد المقرات العسكريه
التابعه لقوات النظام على محور بلده
كفروما في ريف القذائف والصواريخ
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده حيث اكد محامي رئيس
الامريكيه انتهاء تفتيش وزاره العدل الذي
نفذته في منزل الرئيس صباح اليوم مشيرا
الى انهم لم يجدوا شيئا واكدت وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه ان التفتيش لا علاقه له
بقضيه العثور على وثائق سريه في منزل تعود
لفتره خدمته كنائب رئيس لبرك اوباما اكد
انه سيتعاون مع التحقيقات رغم نافيه ان
تكون الوثائق المكتشفه سريه ولها طابع سري
ينضم الينا من واشنطن حسين الطود مراسل
العربيه حسين يعني تفاصيل هذه
ما جرى اليوم يعني بمنزل الرئيس الامريكي
بايدون وماذا سينتج عنه
تحيه لك
البحث استمر لحوادث ثلاثه ساعات في منزل
في ولايه درر لكن كما تفضلت في الخبر
اعلنت اعلن المحققون انهم لم يعثر على اي
وثائق طبعا موضوع عن الوثائق وثائق بعيدا
ووثائق
الرئيس الامريكي السابق
ووثائق ترامب هي اا تتصدر العناوين هذه
الايام هنا في الولايات المتحده ولكن
التركيز من البيت الابيض من الديمقراطيين
هو اعلن الرئيس الامريكي يتعاون هذا البحث
الذي جرى اليوم كان مخطط له وكان بالتعاون
مع الرئيس الامريكي هذا هو التركيز الان
همم في وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه ومن قبل
داعمي رئيس يحاولون التركيز على ان الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب لم يتعاون مع وزاره
العدل لم يتعاون مع المحققين الفيدراليين
فيما ايضا بالنسبه لنائبه همم السابق
هو تعا انه الديمقراطيون الان لا يهاجمون
هجومهم على همم طبعا همم من المتوقع ان
يستمر مسلسل البحث عن وثائق سريه اخرى هذا
وهو متوقع في همم هذه الايام وهذا ما
يستشير اليه وسائل الاعلاميه كبرى هناك
تحركات في كواليس الامريكي لوضع اليات
لحفظ هذه الوثائق بعد انتهاء الرؤساء من
فتره اخذتهم وايضا من قبل حتى بالنسبه
لمسؤولين في مجلس الشيوخ او مجلس النواب
حدث عن اعضاء النواب او اعضاء في مجلس
الشيوخ كي لا تتسرب الوثائق ولا تتسرب
المعلومات السريه كما حدث مع همم عندما
اثروا على وثائق همم كان طلع عليها عندما
كان همم عضوا في مجلس الشيوخ شكرا لك احسن
على هذه المعطيات حسين الطوب مراسل
العربيه حدثتنا منه
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
تحت عنوان ليله صوت الارض تكريم الفنان
طلال طلال مداح في الرياض
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد هي الاكبر في عهد الملك
تشارلز للمطالبه بزياده الاجور وتحسين
شروط العمل اضرب مئات الالوف في بريطانيا
اليوم في قطاعات التعليم والنقل والخدمه
المدنيه كما شارك الالاف في المسيره ساره
في وسط لندن في اتجاه مقر رئاسه الحكومه
وطالب المدرنون المعتصمون بزياده اجور
تعوض التراجع الكبير الذي تسببت به معدلات
التضخم الفعليه التي فاقت العشره بالمئه
في المملكه المتحده
[تصفيق]
هو اضخم اضراب في بريطانيا منذ عشر سنوات
الاف العمال بينهم موظف الخدمه المدنيه
والمحاضرون الجامعيون والمدرسون و سائق
القطارات وداعمهم في مسيره احتجاج شقت
طريقها من وسط لندن باتجاه مقر رئاسه
الحكومه للمطالبه بتحسين الاجور وظروف
العمل من
اجورنا فعليا
وحتى مع زياده المطروحه فان تضخم خفض
رواتبنا
الكلمه
منذ فتره الوباء وعدم تقديم زياده في
الاجور ولا زياده لدعم التلاميذ الضعفاء
الذين تاثروا بالوباء
الاف النقاط الاعتصام شكلها المضربون عن
العمل في مختلف القطاعات للضغط على
الحكومه التي طرحت رفع الاجور بنسبه 5%
وهو ما ترفضه النقابات في ظل نسبه التضخم
تجاوزت 10 في المئه وغلاء معيشه غير مسبوق
ريش هناك اذان الاضرابات التي اجبرت
ملايين التلاميذ على التغيب عن المدارس
وانتقد السياسه رئيس حزب العمال المنحزه
للنقابات
لمعارضه مشروع قانون يؤمن الحد الادنى من
السلامه كما سوت مع مجموعه اوقف استخداما
نفذ لتخفيف من قانون النظام العامه
المشترك بين النقابات ومجموعه اوقف النفط
زعيم المعارضه كير ستار مار من جهته لام
حزب المحافظين الحاكمه لفشله في التعاطي
مع الاضرابات
بعد 13 عاما في السلطه يريد لون حزب
العمال على فشله في ايجاد حل للاضرابات
انه امر مثير للشفقه حزب المحافظين صار
مدمنا على الفساد والفضائح
اضرابات مجدوله في عدد من القطاعات هذا
الاسبوع والاسبوع المقبل ولا مؤشر على
الغائها ما تعثر المفاوضات بين الحكومه
والنقابات
في ما تتمسك الحكومه بزياده رواتب معقوله
تقول النقابات العمال ان الاضرابه مؤشر
على غضب اعضائها وتحذر من المزيد منها ما
لم تطرح الحكومه مقترحات ملموسه وذات مغزى
بشان رفع الاجور مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
الينا
من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى امام هذه
الرساله الواضحه التي ترسلها اليوم
النقابات لانه لا يمكن للحكومه تجاه
المطلب الاجور العادله كيف هي الصوره من
هناك وما هي خارطه يعني الاحتجاج ورد فعل
الحكومه للايام المقبله
يعني ما تريد النقابات مختلفه النقابات هو
ان ترضخ الحكومه لمطالبها ورفع اجور
المضربين عن العمل في عده قطاعات ولكن
الحكومه يعني تبدو
متعمده لتنفيذ هذه المطالب وتقول بان لو
تم زياده اجور هؤلاء المضربين عن العمل
بنسبه التضخم التي تتجاوز 10% حاليا سيكون
مكلف لدافع الضرائب وسيدخل الاقتصاد في
مزيد من المشاكل همم مثل شهيدنا في
الفترات الماضيه لذا الحكومه تقول بانها
منفتحه على التفاوض ولكن يجب ان تكون اي
زياده معقوله تتناسب مع طبيعه العمل ولكن
ايضا في نفس الوقت يجب ان تكون هناك بعض
الاصلاحات في هذه القطاعات وبالتالي همم
المشكله الاضرابات تبدو انها ستستمر في ظل
هذا الخلاف القائم بين النقابات وبين
الحكومه التي تريد ان تمرض قانونا يحج من
من هذه الاضطرابات
الواسعه وتريد ان تضمن حد ادنى من الخدمات
الاساسيه في مختلف البلاد الحاصل هناك
مصطفى حول مشروع هذا القانون الذي يعني
يؤمن الحد الادنى من الخدمات هل ممكن ان
يمر هذا القانون وسطى همم كل الجدل الحاصل
بيننا بين يعني النقابات وحزب العمال مع
رشي سوناك وكل الاحزاب الباك
يعني هذا التشريع هو تم تمريره في من قبل
النواب لانه هناك اغلبيه لحزب المحافظين
الحاكم ولكن هناك تعقيدات ومشاكل تعترض
الحكومه في مجلس الوردات ويبدو ان العثرات
الاولى بدات تتكشف مع اثاره همم اعضاء
مجلس الاوردات العديد من النقاط بخصوص هذا
التشريح ولكن ننتظر يعني كيفيه التعامل
الحكومه مع هذه المقترحات من مجلس الورده
وبالتالي هذا التشريح حتى وانت يعني
سيتطلب بعض الوقت لتمريره ولكن ربما لن
يكون بالصيغه التي طرحتها الحكومه وهي
تقول يقولون المعارضون بانها ستعد من حقوق
همم الناس في خوض اضراب للمطالبه همم
بحقوقهم في مثلا همم برفع الاجور وخاصه
وان هذه الاجور تدلت وتراجعت بسبب همم
نسبه التضخم المرتفعه ايضا بسبب التقشف
الذي الذي شهدته البلاد خلال العشره سنوات
الماضيه لم يعني يتم هناك زياده هذه
الاجور بنسب تتماشى مع نسبه التضخم في
حينها ولكن الان اصبح الوضع ربما اكثر
تعقيدا بسبب التضخم المرتفع شكرا لك مصطفى
زار ومراسل عربيه حدثتنا من لندن
[موسيقى]
تشهد الرياض حفل تكريم الفنان السعودي
طلال مداح الذي رحل قبل اكثر من 22 عاما
تحت عنوان ليله صوت الارض ويشارك في الحفل
الذي ترعاه هيئه الترفيه السعوديه اكثر من
40 فنان عربيه من ثلاثه عشره دوله لتكريم
الفنان الراحل الذي امتد عطائه الفني
لاكثر من نصف قرن ولا يزال راسخا في ذاكره
السعوديين والعالم العربي وهذه الصور
مباشره مشاهدينا الان من هذا الحفل الذي
يقام في العاصمه الرياضيه
[موسيقى]
وشمال
ووردك يا زارع الورد
[موسيقى]
مكرم واحد من رموز الاغنيه السعوديه
الرموز المهمه الاغنيه السعوديه
ومشاركه الاساتذه الكبار في هذه الليله
سواء من المملكه العربيه السعوديه او من
الوطن العربي كلها هذا يعني مدعات للفخر
والسعاده
ويدل على مكانه الفن السعودي والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه يكفي انك تشوفي الان انه
اسم المسرح اسم الفنان العرب محمد عبده و
يتكرم في رفيق دار ابو طلال مداح هذه هذه
الرساله للجميع يعني انا بمبسط باي هيك
لمسه من لمسات الوفاء لانه انا كثير بشجع
الوفاء وفي ناس هيك بحس فيهم الروح بابا
الاستاذ طلال مداح منها الناس لانه خصوصي
كمان بتذكر انه بابا كانت الاغاني
الخليجيه اللي حافظها كانت قليله همم بس
كانت وترحل من ضمن الاغاني اللي كان
بيرددها دائما بدري ليش هيك يعني بحس انه
الاستاذ طالعه الله يرحمه في مره روح بابا
هاي النوع من الحفلات التجمعات اللي بيكون
عنوان
شو الوفاء بصراحه شيء بيثرج الصدر ويخلي
الواحد عاجز عن عن التعبير بصراحه شايف
غيرنا صوت الارض اا
راح الكبير طلال مداح في يوم تكريمه همم
هو يوم تكريم لجميع فنانين السعوديه
والعرب بشكل عام يعني انا ممكن من اكثر
الناس سعاده وفرح
بتكريم الاستاذ طلال رحمه الله عليه لاني
انا
يمكن عاشرته فتره طويله ممتده الى 32 سنه
قدم اللي فيها في بدايات الحان وقدمت له
الحان ايضا همم علاقه طويله يعني حلقات
عشان احكي عنها لكنني سعيد
وفرحان الليله بهذه الليله الكبيره
[موسيقى]
اعتقل الشرطه الباكستانيه 23 شخصا على
خلفيه تفجير استهدف مسجد في مجمع للشرطه
او ده بحياه 100 وشخص وابقى مسؤول رفيعه
طلب عدم الكشف عن هويته كما تحقق السلطات
في احتمال ان يكون اشخاص داخل المجمع
ساعدوا في تنسيق الهجوم وقال المسؤول
الرفيع ان السلطات اعتقلت اشخاصا من صفوف
الشرطه لتحديد الكيفيه التي وصلت فيها
المتفجرات الى الداخل ولمعرفه ان كان اي
مسؤولين في الشرطه متورطين ايضا في
الاعتداء اشيرتنا الى انه قد تكون المهاجم
والاشخاص الذين سهلوا وصوله علاقات خارج
باكستان
[موسيقى]
افاد تقرير امريكي بتعثر سوق العملات
المشفره في عام 2022 حيث تضاءلت الرغبه في
المخاطره وانهارت العديد من شركات التشفير
وتعرض المستثمرون لخسائر كبيره التقرير
اضاف ان قراصنه كوريا الشماليه سرقوا 1.7
مليار دولار من العملات المشفره العام
الماضي ووفقا للتقرير فقد اعتمدت كوريا
الشماليه بشكل متزايد على القرصنه لتمويل
برامجها الصاروخيه والاسلحه النوويه
بعد اكثر من خمسه عقود على رحلتها الاولى
تطويع شركه بوينج صفحه مهمه في مجال
الطيران المدني بتوقفها عن انتاج نسختها
الشهيره سفن فورس 7 وتسلم الشركه اخر نسخه
منها لشركه اطلس اير وهي طائره مخصصه
للشحن في مراسم نحضرها الاف الموظفين
والزبائن والموردين السابقين والحاليين
للشركه هذا وساهمت هذه النسخه في شعاع
السفر جوا في متناول كل الفئات ونقلت
الرؤساء الامريكيين وبفضل حجمها ما كان
طائره 7 فور 7 طبق الوسطى من السفر خارج
اوروبا او الولايات المتحده باسعار معقوله
يشهدوا العالم
ظهر فلكيه هي الاولى منذ 50,000 عام حيث
يقترب ما يعرف من مذنب الاخضر من كوكب
الارض بطريقه يمكن رؤيته بالعين المجرده
في اوقات معينه وبحسب موقع سبيس دوت كوم
سيكون المذنب قابلا للرص لايام عندما
يقترب من الارض ثم يبتعد في طريقه الى
خارج النظام الشمسي
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
التنظيم
الى اوكرانيا
اهداف مشروعه
الكردستان الايراني
اقليم كردستان
وخلال تفتيش المفاجئ وكاله الطاقه الدوليه
تعلن اكتشاف اجهزه طرد مركزي غير معلن
عنها في ايران
[تصفيق]
بريطانيا تشهد اكبر اضراب في عهد الملك
تشارلز
التاسعه انتهت مشاهدين لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360 وزملاء
راويه وطاهر
راويه وطاهر ماذا لديكم لن اعلق على ما
اسمعه من الرشيد
[ضحك]
هذا اليوم الكبير بتاريخ الاضرابات
والاكبر بتاريخ بريطانيا
التي ستزود بها اوكرانيا ومواجز اخباريه
قريبا باحدث تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي
ومؤسسه انستغرام هما من يقوم بذلك بدنا
نحضر حالنا بقى الحقبه الجديد ههه